una emergencia de salud mundial la ms
decretó el nivel más alto de alerta para
la viruela del mono
without break
hemos tenido un brote que se ha
esparcido en el mundo rápidamente con
nuevas formas de transmisión de lo cual
hemos comprendido muy poco la api side
del club he decidido que el brote global
de la viruela del mono representa una
emergencia pública de preocupación
internacional cáncer sin embargo pedrós
decretó la emergencia a pesar de su
comité de expertos nueve miembros de 15
se mostraron en contra tras una reunión
el jueves en ese primer encuentro el 23
de junio los expertos ya habían dicho
que era pronto para la declaración
puesto que podía generar una alarma
excesiva
por su parte para el doctor carlos
álvarez en palabras para france24 es una
forma de mejorar la estrategia
investigando el contagio intensificando
la detección de casos y extendiendo la
vacunación
estas medidas que se toman para permitir
que cada país pues tenga una estrategia
y un plan de trabajo para lograr evitar
que haya una mayor diseminación de esta
epidemia la viruela del mono es una
enfermedad viral que se propaga a través
del contacto cercano causando fiebre
dolor de cabeza de garganta dolores
musculares y lesiones en la piel
genitales o boca hasta el momento se han
registrado 16.000 casos de viruela en 75
países y 5 muertes en áfrica una
virulencia mucho menor que la que tuvo
el commit 19 la última emergencia
sanitaria internacional antes de la
viruela del mono